halsey is bursting with love after
revealing
she's pregnant
[Music]
the 26 year old singer announced the
news on instagram wednesday
sharing three images of her growing baby
bump
she tagged actor producer aylev aiden on
her belly
leading fans to speculate he is the
baby's father
aylev reposted halsey's image to his
instagram story
and also left this sweet comment quote
heart so full i love you sweetness
halsey replied i love you and i love
this mini human
already i am very happy
fans have also noticed that halsey is
wearing a rainbow crochet crop top
and included a rainbow emoji in her
caption
which could be a reference to a rainbow
baby a baby born after a miscarriage or
infant death
i was on tour i found out i was pregnant
and before i could even really
figure out what that meant to me and
what that meant for my future
for my career for my life my
relationship
the next thing i knew i was on stage
miscarrying
in the middle of my concert that's
halsey on an episode of the doctors in
2018
opening up about her struggle with
endometriosis and
suffering pregnancy loss when i finally
got my endometriosis diagnosis was with
dr aliabadi she took one look at me and
i explained her
my symptoms and she said you have
endometriosis and it was so bittersweet
because it was like the relief
of knowing i wasn't making it all up and
i wasn't being sensitive
and it wasn't all in my head but it also
kind of sucked to
know that i was going to be living with
this forever thankfully halsey seems to
be happy
healthy and ready to tackle motherhood i
remind myself that you know
if i'm doing well and the people i love
are happy and taken care of then
everything is good becoming a parent is
something she opened up to rolling stone
about in 2016
telling the mag quote i want to be a mom
more than i want to be a pop star
more than i want to be anything in the
world